on va poursuivre cette partie culturelle
avec une autre invité qui est avec nous
depuis le début de l'édition Mickaël
gioni alors on a commencé à en parler en
début d'émission de votre projet de
votre EP qui est sorti en 2022 c'était
donc son nom c'est 18 avant votre
carrière juste avant de venir dans la
musique ou vous aviez fait des des
études de psychologie c'est ça
[Musique]
toujours fait partie de votre vie
exactement parce que je chante avec ma
grand-mère mon chez moi on écoutait
beaucoup de musique mon papa écoutait
beaucoup de musique donc j'ai toujours
voulu faire carrière dans la musique
mais il fallait faire des études et des
études sérieuses donc j'ai fait des
études en psycho et donc la musique est
toujours restée dans un coin de votre
tête oui que j'en faisais parce que
j'avais les cours de piano je fais les
cours de guitare j'ai fait j'ai fait
aussi comédienne donc j'avais des cours
de théâtre aussi en parallèle et je me
suis dit un moment donné il va bien
falloir que la musique elle sorte et
donc je fais mes studies de psycho et
puis et puis la musique est voilà j'ai
fait des rencontres et puis et puis
c'est parti voilà donc il y a eu cette
EP tout dernièrement qui donc je le dis
ça je le disais ça s'appelle 18 et vous
avez aussi récemment remixé l'un de vos
titres qui s'appelle dépêche-toi d'aimer
on va écouter un extrait tout de suite
[Musique]
je t'aime mélancolie
flouteuse de thé noir et blanc
tu pleures place de l'Étoile
on va parler tout à l'heure de votre
univers pop rock là c'est un titre très
électro vous inspirez notamment de
Madonna c'est ça c'est l'une de vos
sources d'inspirations Madonna depuis
mon plus jeune âge j'aimais beaucoup
Madonna je comprenais pas de l'âge de
dire voilà
mais sinon c'est pris une quand j'ai
fait vraiment j'ai découvert print je me
suis dit
enfin voilà je vais faire un jeu jouer
de la guitare je vais être sur scène
c'est vraiment la scène qui m'attirait
et nous aussi pourquoi je j'ai fait un
peu comédienne aussi et donc non c'est
plus prints qui m'inspire sa folie
et puis son mélange des genres ça ça
m'intéresse
le rock oui ça exprime vraiment ce que
ce que j'écris parce que il y a du
dynamisme il y a la force etc mais mais
oui j'aime ces mélanges et ce remix oui
il est sorti pour aussi pour pour
changer un petit peu j'aime bien
l'électro c'était pour donner une autre
dynamique mais sinon c'est du rock oui
vous avez d'autres styles ça me va bien
ouais très bien j'adore
alors dans les thématiques vous abordez
il y a notamment la thématique de
l'amour qui revient souvent pourquoi
c'est une thématique qui qui fait sens
pour vous qui vous touche que vous aimez
traiter dans votre travail ça parle à
tout le monde et c'est tellement vague
si vous voulez donc je dirais plutôt que
l'amour le sentiment voilà tout ce qui
tout ce qui nous exprime tout ce qui
nous inspire tout ce qu'on ressent donc
plutôt le sentiment que l'amour au sens
vraiment large le sentiment
la mélancolie également l'a dit donc la
musique a toujours fait partie de notre
vie même si finalement vous y êtes
revenus par par la force des choses
étaient notamment directrice artistique
aux côtés d'un d'un photographe c'est ça
qui s'appelle Franck Strom
qui est qui a photographié tout le monde
et qui était aussi reporter de guerre et
donc j'étais sa directrice artistique
jusqu'à même encore maintenant ça vous a
enrichi maintenant même dans le
parce que j'ai rencontré le bassiste de
j'en ai plein qui faisait partie des
Rita Mitsouko et donc j'ai commencé à
travailler avec lui un premier single
qui est sorti
avant le P et puis après j'ai fait
d'autres rencontres et puis j'ai
travaillé le P voilà alors dans les
inspirations également il y a Alain
Bashung Christophe encore muse
finalement c'est beaucoup de figures
masculine oui placebo également c'est
beaucoup de figures masculines le rock
on peut pas faire de d'Europe quand on
est une femme bah si la preuve mais
j'aime cette ambiguïté en fait entre une
fille voilà qui est assez
féminine ou qui a voilà des allures très
féminines et qui peut faire du rock
justement avec
[Musique]
beaucoup de
comment dire
[Musique]
de plein de choix
d'énergie c'est pas le mot que cherchait
les projets pour la suite c'est quoi les
projets je continue donc la promo la
suite c'est évidemment la scène donc
voilà ça ça continue et on peut
retrouver votre actualité sur vos
réseaux sociaux
toutes les plateformes et donc bah je
souhaite à tout le monde une bonne
écoute la page Instagram pour retrouver
votre actualité mais le fait 18 est
disponible sur toutes les plateformes
bien sûr musicale merci d'être venu en
parler en PLA